bonjour vous n'êtes pas sur FR3 Toulouse
mais sur FR3 Normandie l'émission n'est
pas présentée par Guy Lux mais par
Jean-Louis Janer je ne suis pas Chantal
Goya mais Mylène Farmer la moquette
n'est pas bleue maigrise et le décor
n'est pas le numéro 61 de rocking chair
avec Mylène Farmer ça s'annonce
je suis né à Montréal au Canada tu es
québécoise je suis québécoise donc et
puis je vis en France depuis maintenant
8 ans et je suis plus française que
canadienne
j'allais dire c'est un accent vulgaire
je suis ça c'est un peu fort mais c'est
un accent que j'aime pas qui n'est pas
très familier
de pas aimer grand chose c'est vrai
j'ai l'impression que tu es quelqu'un
d'un peu
vif je suis quelqu'un oui qui a un
caractère et même un sale caractère mais
pourquoi tu dis ça de toi parce que tu
es parce que ça doit être vrai les
techniciens vous le diront d'ailleurs
ils sont derrière leur caméra ils
peuvent rien dire
la plante était quelqu'un d'un peu dur
non je suis quelqu'un qui aime les
choses bien faites donc j'essaye moi de
faire les choses bien et j'aimerais que
les que les gens fassent la même chose
mais t'as pas l'impression que qu'on
peut qu'on est obligé de travailler avec
tout le monde par exemple quand tu fais
maman à tort ce grand tube qu'on va
découvrir dans quelques instants ce
n'est pas toi qui écrit ni qu'on pose
non en fait nous formons une équipe de
trois personnes il y a Jérôme dans
Laurent Boutonnat et moi-même les deux
garçons composent écrivent musique et
paroles et puis moi j'interprète
c'est pas simple de travailler en équipe
faut que tout le monde se tente bien
c'est difficile mais c'est quand même
très agréable quand on est très lié
c'est important d'avoir des équipes
soudées tu es très lié avec avec les
gens avec lequel tu lesquels tu
travailles très lié oui je les vois je
vois ces deux personnes tous les jours
depuis un an maintenant et on s'entend
très bien tu voulais faire de la chanson
tu étais tu as fait d'autres choses je
m'étais plutôt orientée vers le métier
de
monitrice d'équitation et ensuite j'ai
bifurqué vers les cours de théâtre et
puis j'ai terminé par par mes petites
chanteuses et c'est très bien tu
t'entendais bien avec les chevaux très
très bien
Mylène c'est difficile de faire un tube
parce qu'après quand on doit faire une
deuxième chanson c'est pas simple non
c'est simple pour personne c'est vrai
parce que la grande phrase si on vous
attend au tournant alors on fait en
sorte d'avoir une chanson aussi forte
que la première
et puis d'avoir des prestations aussi
bonnes que les premières c'est pas
simple non c'est pas simple parce que le
public est dur et exigeant et le métier
aussi donc
c'est comme ça que ce filtre au fur et à
mesure et puis il y en a qui reste et
puis d'autres qui partiront il y en a
d'autres qui reviendront et puis tu as
envie de faire une carrière
je crois que c'est le rêve d'être
personne qui débute enfin j'espère
prendre des cours de danse des cours
plein de choses pour pouvoir
éventuellement faire de la scène ah bon
tu as envie de danser en plus bien sûr
cinéma j'espère le cinéma message va
attendre un peu pour l'instant je mets
ce que c'est parce que tu as 23 ans et
tout jeune et que tu te dis que
finalement tu as envie de tout faire
mais tu sais quand on veut tout faire
c'est ce que ils un certain nombre de
gens t'as pas peur qu'on se disperse non
non justement c'est ce dont je parlais
je préfère pour l'instant
me consacrer à la chanson et plus tard
le cinéma s'il fait appel à moi j'y
viendrai quel effet ça fait d'être très
connu à 23 ans c'est sympa c'est
difficile à vivre
pour l'instant ça met pas trop pénible
c'est plus tôt agréable je sais pas avec
peut-être 5 ans de recul je m'en
plaindrai peut-être mais là ça va ça
peut parler en tout cas toi tu as
beaucoup chanté on t'as vu beaucoup
téléradio mais tu as un peu parlé parce
que je disais c'est que dans les
émissions qui sont consacrées aux
variétés la plupart du temps les
interviews passent un peu outre et puis
on a tendance à interviewer quelqu'un
qui est installé depuis 5-10 ans dans le
métier plutôt qu'une jeune personne
et puis les questions sont pas très
souvent intéressantes non plus c'est pas
facile ça aussi de dire bon la technique
ça va pas les questions ça va pas de
toujours de toujours avoir
comment dire tendance à donner les tôles
aux autres et pas à soi c'est un peu
comme maman à tort finalement c'est pas
toi qui a peur là à nouveau c'est tout
là toujours les autres qu'on l'État
c'est facile non c'est bien oui
non non je reconnais tous mes torts mais
c'est vrai que j'aime bien accuser les
gens aussi mais quand j'en ai la
conviction je
le dis une fille facile comme on dit sur
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de caractère
bah oui j'ai du caractère une fille
facile ça je ne sais pas qu'est-ce que
tu aimes là c'est aller chanter devant
les gens quand on fait les gala plutôt
que de faire toujours des télés des
radios être loin de du public oui je
veux dire quelque chose de banal c'est
peut-être le contact direct avec le
public et puis c'est surtout une
performance
tout à l'heure tu voulais danser je suis
des cours de danse une fois par jour
une heure c'est déjà crevant c'est très
très difficile en fait pour faire ce
métier
je ne sais pas du tout
c'est vrai que si j'ai à monter un
spectacle ce sera 8h par jour mais pour
l'instant j'ai pas mal de choses à faire
j'ai la promotion de ce disque on est
tous des imbéciles
et tu aimes tu aimes aller voir d'autres
spectacles de grands ou de grandes de ce
métier ou c'est
plus facilement au cinéma
oh c'est sans doute par fainéantise
aller chercher sa place faire la queue
mais c'est un peu en fait il y a le même
phénomène que le cinéma une fois qu'on
est dans la salle c'est un ravissement
mais
se déplacer aller chercher sa place ou
ça c'est très pénible je suis très finie
alors qu'est-ce que tu fais quand tu es
chez toi tu regardes la télé ça m'arrive
de regarder la télé mais je lis je
réfléchis m'arrive de peindre aussi non
je parle ou des petits-enfants qui sont
tout maires un peu comme moi
où je peins des paysages un peu
fantastiques je suis attirée par ces
choses avec l'envie de je sais pas
d'aller exposer non ou c'est vraiment là
de l'ordre encore du plaisir personnel
oui exposé
je crois que rien n'est fait par hasard
il faut avoir vraiment du talent et je
n'aurais pas exposé mes peintures non
parce que pas quelque chose que je
revendique qu'est-ce que tu penses du du
rock Mylène toi parce que bon rocking
chamission drogue c'était invité parce
que je trouve que c'est pas toujours ce
qui est tout à fait
savoir qu'est-ce qui se cachait derrière
ce ce visage un peu comme ça un petit
peu flou cette image floue que tu
renvoies tu veux que je te parle du rock
j'écoute très peu le rock avec et je
vais un peu du mal à le définir
qu'est-ce que tu écoutes alors comme
musique
j'écoute un peu de musique classique
j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup Wagner sinon
il m'arrive d'écouter de la variété
française j'aime bien Gainsbourg j'aime
bien ce qu'a fait à Jenny
et puis il m'arrive d'écouter aussi de
la variété anglo-saxonne j'aime beaucoup
Paul Lyon
les Beatles j'aime bien j'aime bien
Julio Iglesias si
sérieusement c'est un monsieur qui a
énormément de talent je trouve alors
donc tu penses que le que le talent
tu les finis comment toi le talent alors
dans le rock ou ailleurs c'est c'est
quoi c'est ça senti c'est ce qu'on
ressent ou c'est les gens qui se
précipitent comme ça pour décréter que
quelqu'un a du talent
pas le talent ça peut être ça peut être
c'est un tout surtout ça peut être une
belle voix ça peut être
[Musique]
de bonnes interprétations et puis c'est
surtout une aura enfin quelque chose qui
a une personne ce que dégage une
personne t'as pas l'impression quand tu
dis ça si par exemple tu dis un public
un certain type de public que tu aimes
relu avec les sciences ou quelqu'un
d'autre que tu peux te couper dans notre
public
justement non ce qui se passe pour
rouler iglesiaste puisqu'on en parle à
quand même un public très très vaste
d'accord
de
rock si les mers ou l'eau je pense qu'on
peut aimer les deux contraires parce que
dans le rock on a aussi tendance à le
mettre dans un carcan je trouve qu'il
faut c'est l'argir le rang qui a du hard
rock imagine après voilà d'accord donc
tu n'as pas peur véritablement toi te
couper les autres en affirmant qui tu es
ce que tu penses au contraire je crois
que je me rapprocherai des gens
dans ce métier c'est vrai que j'ai un
privilège c'est de pouvoir mentir et
dire n'importe quoi
je joue un peu avec les deux donc
vous avez entendu tout le monde j'en
prenais et vous en laissez
[Musique]